computing and simulations thank you okay
so I'm happy to be here and sorry I
missed most of the rest of the day but I
guess this is the last talk of the day
and we'll will conclude with a hardware
talk this being the building of quantum
information processors using atoms
individual atoms and these are charged
atoms trapped ions and there's a picture
of sort of the best of everything in
terms of the number of ions that we are
currently manipulating about 50 or so in
a linear ion trap I'm not going to talk
too much about that I'll return later to
the to the most advanced chip traps that
we're using this one is built by Sandia
and interestingly it's the this is the
only quantum computing hardware that
uses conventional silicon fabrication
this is a conventional silicon
fabricated set of electrodes it's plated
with gold but there are no individual
impurities it's room temperature system
so there's nothing really exotic here
of course we afforded that because the
quantum system is not in the silicon
it's not solid-state and this is why
it's why the qubits are so good there
are atoms there atomic clock qubits so
I'll talk about this and as we go
through so this is a should always be
careful picking the claiming that you
know the winning hardware's are this is
from an article on science a review
article a few years ago
plotting several of the leading
candidates to build quantum computers
and I would say these top two
superconducting circuits and trapped
ions are really there's a big gulf
between these two and the rest of them
and the and and it's because these
systems are now called systems they're
being built into systems they're no
longer physics experiments and I think
that's really important in this field
that we have systems that can be used by
a third party somebody that doesn't know
or care what the qubits are made of but
like any computer can can use it in an
abstract way and indeed we're seeing
these things being built up and there's
big investments in both these
technologies so it's no no no surprise
that those two are sort of leading
candidates now to back that up
this is a plot of the the error per two
qubit gate over time and we can see in
these two technologies things are
getting really good really fast and the
two things I want to mention here is
that the state of the art is around
three 9s in these technologies we think
we know how to go further but you should
also sort of dispense with this plot
right away because all of these data
points involve exactly two qubits and no
more and so that means there are lots of
other errors that will pop in when you
want to scale the system when you want
to build a system this is this plots
sort of irrelevant that's good
and maybe we've heard a similar kind of
similar version of this in the
superconducting technology from John's
talk ok so trapped atomic guy in qubits
as I mentioned the the the beauty of
atomic qubits is that their standards
actually literally their frequency
standards their atomic clocks so they're
identical they're more identical than
you can make anything identical that's
why we use them to define the second so
the qubits are done there no they will
never be improved they're way better
than we need to be we can make qubits
identical to a part in 10 to the 15 if
we really need to fortune we don't need
to so that's not the issue the issue of
course is that while the atoms are
perfect qubits it's the control system
around them that is where all the
challenges are in this type of a qubit
and in that sense it's sort of
complimentary to many solid state
platforms where the controllers again
can can can really leverage the the VLSI
and and solid-state fabrication over the
last several decades and their materials
will improve but always will be limited
by the fact that each qubit is a
man-made qubit and there are in
homogeneity and so forth that's not the
problem here
so with trapped atomic ions and atomic
qubits in general we can read them out
use I'm not going to go into too many
details here maybe you heard a little
bit about this before we can read them
out using laser fluorescence depending
on the qubit state the atom flores's or
it doesn't and you can get a
near-perfect measurement per qubit in a
single shot and by near-perfect I mean
the record is like four or five nines
of fidelity and if you only have a
hundred cubits you don't even need that
so it again there are lots of things
when you build the system you shouldn't
go too far in any one dimension you
don't need six nines of anything yet
unless you have a million cubit I
mentioned we can do high fidelity
entangling gates I'll talk a little more
about that the coherence times are
incredibly long they can they've been
measured to be at least 10 minutes it's
probably longer than that and the system
itself indeed the bad news is we have
lasers all over the place and the
systems are held in a vacuum these atoms
are suspended above this chip in a
vacuum chambers you can't have air
colliding with the system so that's a
little exotic a little difficult to
think about building a future computer
with lasers and vacuum systems but
that's the price you pay for having
pristine qubits but we can do lots of
things with a room-temperature apparatus
which is another bonus okay so I'm gonna
talk about a few couple of different
topics here and and they're quite
related and the first one will be how do
we make gates between these ions these
lasers that I mentioned how are they
used to wire together these atomic
qubits and the story is actually it's a
very a lot of its classical physics were
applying forces to these atoms using
lasers very much like optical tweezers
push around dielectric bodies cells or
whatever in this case I again I totally
skipped over ion trapping technology
here we have a linear chain of about 20
I on Zoar so they're separated by
several microns that separation is a
balance between the Coulomb repulsion
and the external confinement and in this
case it's obvious that the one of the
three axes of confinement is very weak
compared to the other two and that's why
they line themselves along a linear
chain like this so we're going to store
qubits inside the atoms actually in
hyperfine States I didn't talk about
that these are effective spin states
within the atoms but they're going to
couple there there's no wires obviously
between the atoms but we can couple them
through their through their collective
motion mediated by the Coulomb
interaction it's the idea is if we want
to entangle any pair of these ions in
the chain we can send a laser beam
specially tuned and focused to
individually address
target qubits that you honor entangle
and importantly these laser beams will
apply a force that depends on the qubit
state we call it a state dependent or
spin dependent force so if the atom is
in the state 1 it moves up and if it's
in the state 0 moves down and of course
if you have a superposition of 0 and 1
then you're splitting the atom in two
places you're making a little little
interferometer that way and the point
the whole point here is that the Coulomb
interaction is nonlinear and that is if
you look at the four possibilities of
these two states of these two qubits if
you're in 1 1 or 0 0 their Coulomb
interaction is exactly the same as it
was but if they're in opposite states
then the atoms are a little further
apart and there's a tiny defect in the
Coulomb energy it gives rise to a dipole
or one of our cubed force this is in one
regime by the way you're gonna ask what
happens to all the other ions isn't it
like a like pendulums connected by
Springs if you wiggle one pendulum they
all feel it and that's true this this
math works in the in the limit where the
the entangling gate is really fast it's
so fast that we we push the atom then we
return it in a time faster than any of
the motional frequencies and in that
case it is the price you pay it's good
because it's fast but the price you pay
is then you have a range problem the
gate only you can only entangle over
certain distances and if you look at the
four possibilities of those states again
the two states with mixed with mixed
states of qubits suffer a phase shift
the same phase shift and that's why it's
nonlinear and when that phase shift is
set to PI over two its equivalent to a
controlled-not gate in a different basis
just fully entangling okay and in fact
I'm this actually is the physics the
basic physics of what goes on except
that we don't do it this way we don't do
it in the fast way we actually do excite
all the motion and that's a little bit
of a pain in the butt but it's a
classical pain in the butt because we
have to we have to take care of all
those modes of motion and we shape our
laser pulses in a very non-trivial way
we pre calculate laser pulses using the
classical physics of these this Coulomb
interaction to decide how to make sure
that all those modes return to where
they started in there and there's no
entanglement left in those modes we only
want to tangle min on the spins
okay the other one thing I put under the
rug is that we actually do this in a
different basis the X basis not the Z
basis like this z gate here so we are
Native that the best gates and trapped
ions are called mullmer Sorensen Gates
or I call them Ising gates this is the
evolution operator it's just a xx
interaction and by setting the time of
those laser pulses you can realize this
gate it's fairly slow compared to solid
state systems from 10 kilohertz to a
megahertz these gate speeds and the
Fidelity's are depending on the system
if you have only two you should be
expected to do better than three nines
of course okay so this was this is
Mussoorie variation of the physics first
studied by ignacio serac and peter
Zoeller long time ago in 1995 and the
mole Merce Torrence an improvement of
that basic idea is what everybody uses
today so I want to talk about a very
simple experiment that we've started a
few years ago to try to scale this up
again dealing with all these modes of
motion and in doing in doing so in this
experiment this is a schematic of the
experiment the laser beams that drive
that force are actually countered they
have to be counter-propagating but one
of them is focused down to hit the ions
the other ones uniform and the brains of
the operation is really this this
multi-channel optical switch it allows
us to control the amplitude frequency
and phase of any number of beams in fact
this has 32 channels another example of
leveraging the the silicon fab industry
this is made to two edged higher levels
of CMOS actually to have lots of beams
thirty-two beams and a company Harris
corporation makes this and they make it
for us now instead of cutting seamounts
wires we're focusing on individual atoms
and so with five cubits we can basically
we can put all five beams on we can put
individual beams on or we can put all
the ten possible pairs to do all the ten
possible two qubit gates and unlike the
one of our cubes example I showed before
here this is fully connected in fact the
best gate high fidelity fastest one is
the one between one and five that were
furthest apart this has to do with the
normal mode that has the end ones moving
a lot more than the others and it's a
small system so you should always think
about how this
scale and I'll comment on that as we go
what I what we we're a little bit
surprised that in this experiment we
should maybe we shouldn't have been is
that it allowed us an opportunity for
once in atomic physics to enjoy the full
stack of this tiny quantum computer I've
been operating my whole life pretty much
way down here playing around at the atom
laser interactions and turning screws to
make vacuum pumps work and so forth and
lasers lasers and lasers I mentioned at
a higher level we need to shape these
laser pulses classically and so there's
some classical overhead it's it's linear
with the number of qubits so it's not so
bad the prefactor is like eight though
it's at a ten well when is five it's not
so bad but it is it's not so bad so we
think we can scale well beyond five here
but then we go up one notch and we have
these xx gates and rotation gates but
the textbooks have controlled nuggets
and Hadamard so we need to compile if we
if there's an algorithm the very top
some textbook algorithm it's usually in
the textbook gates gate language and we
have to do this compilation step to
interpolate and so when we when we get
things set up in the morning we can
actually run from the very top for many
hours which is really cool this is we're
sort of abstracting away the the the
device and that that that's again it
shouldn't been a surprise I guess but
the performance of this was such that we
could we could do some pretty fun things
and so one example again their textbook
gates small gates
sorry small algorithms with just a few
qubits that we can sort of test the
system on and these are these Oracle
type algorithms are actually nice
benchmarks for small systems they give
you a yes or no answer it doesn't mean
that you can understand all the errors
that were in there but when you're
testing small systems algorithms like
this even though Bernstein vows irani
algorithm is full of Clifford gates only
you could argue about the depth of
entanglement all that but in any case
there is entanglement in in the
algorithm for all these Oracle's and
it's a good way to benchmark the system
so Bernstein Voss irani to refresh your
memory is a into one bit function where
we don't know some some bit string that
is hardwired in the system it's it's the
Oracle it includes a seat and the
question is what is that n bit string
see
classically we of course have to
evaluate every bit of the of C using
separate experiments so the end
evaluations but quantum mechanically we
do just once you all know this I'm sure
by having superposition so this is a
this is a circuit diagram for a four
qubit Bernstein buzzer running algorithm
the fifth qubit like many algorithms
it's an Scylla qubit and you can see
this the structure is very symmetrical
here and the Oracle basically puts a C
not gate wherever the C vector the C bit
is high so this is an example for the
one-one-one-one oracle of course there
are 16 possible Oracle's and then at the
end of the day when we measure these
four first four cubits C comes right out
just in that structure there and so in
our five qubit system at Maryland we we
built 16 circuits here with each of the
16 Oracle's and we made a simple
measurement of the output state single
shot with the efficient the the
single-shot efficiencies but 99.2% per
gate sorry per qubit so you can see the
errors are not zero in the end the
probability of success was in the you
know ninety percent range
eighty to ninety percent range not
unreasonable because these gates the C
not gates have six rotations in one I
sing gate and we have the Hadamard gates
have three rotation gates so there's a
lot of gates here actually and and the
way errors accumulate it's not
unreasonable to expect that so we wanted
of course this to be a 1 along the
diagonal ok so the reason the reason I'm
putting this up is that we we we got a
call from our friend Martin rattler at
Microsoft who was playing around at the
IBM quantum experience you know that
they have abstracted away their hardware
and you can get this on the cloud and
they ran this algorithm this is Jerry
Chow and Jay Gambetta who engineered the
system behind them and they ran the same
algorithm on the IBM system and got
similar results you know that their
gates are not as good as the iron gates
but decent enough to see the clear
correlation between input and output
state the real key difference in these
two systems is the connectivity that
qubits and with only five cubits you
could argue connectivity doesn't matter
exists systems tiny but this is the unit
cell of a square
of course and their connectivity is
pretty weak here and it you know there's
an architectural and a computer science
issue here how do you assign qubits to
such a graph here it doesn't matter we
can do any gate here you'd you'd obvious
that the fifth qubit should be the
middle because it's the one that needs
the connections to all the others so
it's another example of you know
theorists at the very top doing
algorithms and compilers they need to
know the hardware they need to know
aspects of the hardware maybe some of
these gates have errors and you want to
not use those some of these connections
could have errors you'd want to use them
so much so one other example of a guru
and this is another Oracle algorithm
called the hidden shift and this is
where Martin rattler really had troubles
I think he had something to do with the
original version of hidden shift here
you're given two functions and they're
the same functions it's just that the
inputs are offset by some unknown string
s this time Ian exponentially many you
have to evaluate about half of all the
inputs to triangulate and figure out
what that shift was quantum mechanically
once again just once in a single shot
you can get that and this is an example
it's a five cubed circuit and these are
the sorry it's a four qubit hidden shift
algorithm there's a fifth qubit I didn't
draw here but this is a certain
functions called the bent function
almost doesn't matter what the function
is but the shift once again is encoded
in this Oracle in a certain way it's
maybe not so obvious this is for the
shift one zero one zero and you can see
in general this algorithm requires more
connectivity and this is the result in
the two systems again just five cubits
once again this is actually a deeper
circuit quite a bit in our system so the
errors are a little more 80 percent or
so and the IBM system it really really
took a nosedive and of course the reason
is because it's not well connected so
the lesson there is is a connectivity
really matters now you could also argue
that you know this is this is the
probably the worst example of the IBM
system because when they build their
square lattice it's going to be more
powerful and that's certainly true but
just the point here is an architectural
point connectivity really matters and we
don't have a cloud but we have again I'm
grad students and postdocs that go down
in the lab in the morning they tune the
system up and then in the afternoon it's
kind of fun they can run from a laptop
or from their PC controller
for many hours in the afternoon so this
system could be on the cloud not yet and
we've we've had fun running lots of
other mostly Oracle types of algorithms
and they're all trivial because we're
talking about just a few qubits and you
know the gate depths here this the
simulation of a few site Fermi Hubbard
model actually took took the most gates
we've done so far but I want to comment
briefly on on one involving seven cubits
we're moving to nine as well in this
system and in the seven qubit system
this is a physics result not so relevant
to quantum computing maybe or maybe not
if you want to make a Chronicle here in
a black hole you might want to know
about scrambling quantum scrambling is
you might might know or have heard
scrambling is a subtle concept that's
more than just entanglement but it
involves information that totally
diffuses in the entire Hilbert space and
it's thought to occur in black holes if
you want to model black hole as a
unitary process we see we think of black
holes as being the fastest possible
scramblers information everywhere it's
sort of like decoherence except it's a
closed system so it's not really
decoherence but the structure of
entanglement and the scrambling unitary
is incredibly dense very deep and
there's lots of work on this connecting
it to the black hole information paradox
Patrick Hayden John Prescott and Lenny
Susskind collaborators as well so there
there are some approaches to measure
scrambling by measuring so-called out of
time order correlators if you take a
quantum system you volve it forward and
backward in time and make correlation
measurements you can say something about
how this system scrambles in fact if
your correlation correlators decay then
you then that's an indication of
scrambling anytime a signal it decays
and you're trying to show some physics
you have to be careful because there's
lots of reasons signals decay and so the
difference in this experiment is that
it's a positive test for quantum
scrambling and involves a circuit it's a
very simple circuit 7 qubits here and we
have our unit aries there are only three
qubit unitary so these are pretty small
black holes but we need to implement the
unitary and it's inverse which is if
it's circuit it's not hard to do that
the idea here and this is pointed out by
my collaborator Normie out here in the
audience from Berkeley and Benny have
seen it from prim
that if if you scrambles then you can
make a circuit that will give rise a
conditional teleportation of an unknown
state so the idea is you prepare an
unknown state here all the others are
initialized at zero and if and only if
this unitary scrambles based on a based
on a measurement of any of these bell
pairs or you can hardwire it with a
Grover Grover circuit we've done both of
those in any case based on some
conditions on these qubits that unknown
state gets teleported here and the
fidelity of the teleportation tells you
whether it's scramble or not and the
good news is if there's decoherence or
other things going on it's bad or even
if you isn't U and u dagger aren't
exactly the the inverses of each other
then that will only cause the
measurements to have a lower yield it
won't affect the fidelity of
teleportation so in that sense we've
separated the scrambling aspect of our
signal from the the dirty stuff and by
the way you can't read this maybe I did
that on purpose but the unitary we use
is a very general one it's sort of a
permutation unitary a fractional
permutation unitary and we have
rotations in here and what's cool about
this unitary is that it has a parameter
theta and when theta is 0 there is no
scrambling you don't expect it when thay
is PI over 2 it should be maximally
scrambling and when we measure the
teleportation fidelity again if you're
less than 1/2 then there is no the
fidelity I mean fidelity of 1/2 is like
having zero teleportation is you can
classically move information with a
fidelity of 1/2 on average and we can
see as we increase theta
indeed the teleportation field goes up
and it doesn't go up to 100% we this is
a pretty deep circuit as always errors
are adding up just an example of of what
you can do with lots of lots of qubits
and of course when we get when we get 64
128 qubits we're going to continue along
this path of looking at scrambling and
much more complicated systems so this is
some data and background there's in this
recent paper ok so now I'm gonna I guess
simulators was in my title officially so
fortunately the physics of how we make a
simulator versus making a gate based
trapped ion system is almost identical
here we're simply going to apply
instead of focusing laser beams we're
gonna hit them all with a big fat beam
and then we have an all on all Ising
interaction and instead of having
individual beams hit down we have two
fat beams which by the way is a lot
easier in the lab and we end up having a
full all on all icing icing coupling
here and we can apply a transverse field
in any direction that's easy to do just
by doing putting multiple tones on these
laser beams to flip the spins
simultaneously along any axis now
importantly this J matrix the Ising
matrix it's long range and it falls off
with a very good approximation according
to a power law in distance and we can
vary that power law in practice between
about 0.5 and 1.5 in theory we should be
able to go from all all-to-all to one of
our cube dipolar the sweet spot between
0.5 and 1.5 but it's pretty long range
and the the technique that we use here
that we don't use in gates is that the
motional modes are only virtually
excited where this force is way off
resonance so you can you can ad back
eliminate the phonons and that means
that the speed of this operation is a
lot slower than the gates so instead of
10 to 100 kilohertz it's more like 1
kilohertz so it's just it's slowing down
the whole system but it's fully
connected as well and we can go out in
long times if you want to call if you
want to calculate gate depth you know
it's it's it's large even though these
aren't gates so it's a very simple
example yeah and there's this is a
different this is not exactly an Ising
model so called XY mall or a flip-flop
model we can add multiple tones to get
that as well and what's neat about this
Hamiltonian is that the excitation
number is conserved if you flip one spin
and if two spins flip then then the
number of spin up atoms in the chain is
the same and so in this experiment this
is a dynamics experiment and it sort of
has generated lots of lots of other
types experiments like this studying the
dynamics of these long range interacting
systems lots of entanglement of course
here we started with one atom in the
spin up state or one state all the
others in zero
now when weak which to this Hamiltonian
we're going to always have only one
bright atom one
spin spin up atom in the chain and when
we let the system evolve for what we
would say is a decent gate depth if you
want this excitation is hardly moved
this is an average of course of a few
thousand runs and in every single shot
the the the excitation appears in some
place but it's mostly here and you can
see that it sampled the entire even the
last one here it sampled the entire
chain very complicated dynamics here and
if you look more carefully at something
and we'll call this order parameter the
position of the excitation so in the
middle would be zero that would be
negative one where we started and this
is positive one you can see over time
ignore the brown that's just a that's a
an averaged version of the data the raw
data the blue here we see that the the
position stays to the left and it seems
to stop evolving now under the under the
influence of this long-range interaction
there's something expected called pre
thermalization so the systems close how
does it thermal eyes well you when you
trace over subsets you can think about
an individual spin thermal izing to the
rest of the bath but if you look at the
energy spectrum of this long range
interacting system especially for small
alpha where the range of the interaction
is even longer there's always one state
that has a tiny energy gap and the point
here is that gap is getting really small
and it takes forever for true
thermalization if we could observe more
than if we can observe out to 3600 we
expect that blue line to go to zero but
it does Plateau and that's for lack of a
better term been called pre
thermalization and so using this
technique our group and other groups
have done lots of experiments with with
between 5 and 200 trapped ion spins and
in different different systems all in
the guise of quantum simulation with
this with this great control it's not a
quantum computer but in but by some
arguments we're doing things in some
cases that are very difficult or even
impossible to calculate otherwise let me
give you an example of that the last the
last one here is a quench experiment and
it's something we call it dynamical
phase transition I still don't know
exactly what that means but it's not an
equilibrium state so when you talk about
phases we're not talking about
equilibrium phases here we prepare all
the spins along the x axis this is a
Bloch sphere of any one of the spins but
we quench it to
- this transverse Ising model all on all
Ising model and then we simply measure
long X it's one of the simplest
experiments we can do and if depending
on the value of B over J we get
interesting dynamics with B is really
small when B is really small the the the
atoms are along X they're already in an
eigenstate of this Hamiltonian if B is
really small and so nothing really
exciting happens they stay ordered and
they don't evolve so much this is a
measurement of the average magnetization
over all the chain I think this is know
how many spins this is I think this is
maybe 20 or 25 spins at high values of B
when B dominates then these these spins
precess around the z axis and and you
can say that they this is not exactly
thermalization because the rotation
frequencies are all different a little
bit on the spins for me point six yeah
it's pretty long range pretty sure with
that left look that up but when we when
we add lots more spins it turns out this
phase transition by measuring the mean
magnetization is it's very smooth not as
sharp as we'd like in fact in theory
looks a Gorshkov our collaborator as has
helped us understand in theory yeah it's
going to be it's going to evolve very
slowly so we looked at a different order
parameter we looked at a full end body
correlator here and this is data with 53
qubits and we see that as we increase B
over J we see a minimum in the maximum
domain size if we average over many many
runs and I won't get into too many
details here but we this is just data
here the line here is just a fit we
don't understand why it should be that
way and we certainly can't calculate
where this phase transition occurs it's
sort of an infinite temperature phase
transition it's very strange so that's
why it's called a dynamical phase
transition and you can argue that we
can't calculate this we can't prove that
we can't calculate this but we can't
calculate it okay so why 50 well it
turns out that the vacuum I mentioned we
have to pump the air out turns out that
at room temperature the vacuum is not
perfect it's never perfect but at room
temperature there's stuff in the
background and number easy-to-remember
and it's a beautiful atomic physics
collisional calculation each atomic ion
suffers a collision every hour at room
temperature given this typical
background pressure so we can just kind
of brute force turn the pressure down by
going cold so this is an apparatus it's
at 4 Kelvin and 4 Kelvin these days is a
lot easier than it used to be but still
we need optical access so we don't
exactly want to do this so we're kind of
kicking it screaming here but we don't
care about the cold temperature so much
that does help on background but mainly
it lowers the pressures everything
sticks to the surface and at 4 Kelvin
the this this one our number becomes
weeks or something per atom so this is
an image of you'll see a little kink in
the middle of the image because I think
that the chain was so big that they had
to move the they had to move the imager
over to capture both halves of it and
stitches 121 ions and they stay there
all day as long as we're in the lab
importantly there's there's a gap over
here on the right we don't know for sure
but this is either a doubly ionized you
terbium or it's a different isotope of
your terbium that's ER I don't think I
mentioned you terbium that's our ion
there's a different isotope that's not
fluorescing at the right frequency and
what's neat about this what we what we
like about this gap here is that gap
stayed in the same position all day as
long as we had these ions in the trap
that means they never reordered and
that's important so when we want to
scale beyond 50 or so my guess is that
we're gonna need to need to go to 4
Kelvin okay now you might ask well
there's 120 modes of motion you have to
control yeah that's going to be an issue
if we wanted to build our five cubits
system up to 121 there's some issues
there and we have yet to work them out
but we believe that we're not going to
have a fully connected system over this
chain but it will be connected plus or
minus 10 or 20 ions is my guess so your
question
yeah I lost over so many things so these
atoms in a trap you can think of them as
a molecule they're a bunch of atoms
bound right of course they're bound
because we push them together and so you
can do you can do Raman spectroscopy on
the vibrational modes they're normal
modes they're harmonic oscillators
they're lasers are cool to the ground
state so they're very clean and we can
just simply measure the sidebands the
response of these chains to forces and
we take a Raman spectrum with 121
there's a force of modes we've taken
data with up to about 40 spins and just
see we can identify every mode and you
might ask do they drift and so forth
that's a good question and this is these
are things that we have to we have to
work on as we scale the system up we
have again we've just started we only
have one working system and it's
unfortunate as tiny tiny change we only
have so many laser beams we've done
parallel gates on multiple pairs at the
same time and again it's just it's a
classical math problem it gets a little
more they're more constraint so it's a
little harder to do classically but
again with five or seven I don't want to
speculate on where that's going to end
my prediction is that even with 121 ions
we're not going to have to the laser
pulses are not going to add in
complexity and the price you pay is that
they're also going to be somewhat local
so you're not gonna be able to do a gate
between this one and that one but you
can do between this one and maybe that
one there's going to be some distance
over which things work well and this is
this is yet to be mapped out but I
wanted to as I conclude I wanted to
spend a few moments talking about how we
scale beyond this because I I really
don't imagine having more than several
hundred eyes in one chain in fact fifty
or hundred I think might be sufficient
so the idea of course is to make a
modular scalable system where we have a
bunch of collections of small chains
small being somewhere between five and a
hundred or something would be my guess
now I would I would argue that anything
complex if you want to grow it is gonna
have to be modular
and we see this of course in classical
computing multi-core processors you
don't make a bigger chip you make more
chips and connect them together and the
point here is you're limiting
connectivity but you're still growing
the system and that's what we can think
about exploring and certainly in the
trap dying system now my colleague Dave
Wineland many years ago thought
immediately that we're gonna need to
make very complicated ion traps where we
can shuttle ions around in space and
here the modularity is very clear you
could have a bunch of registers where
you do computations and then you
physically pick atoms and move them
around now all of the simple experiments
have been done with shuttling atoms and
maintaining entanglement so forth the
hard part of course is to make to make
the electrode structure and it's not
going to be a typical University type
experiments gonna be one of these chip
traps I showed before and this this will
my prediction is this will allow us to
scale from 50 in a module to maybe few
thousands on a single chip yeah we don't
have that chip yet and you'll probably
almost certainly have to be at 4 Kelvin
and they're loading issues and so forth
a lot of engineering issues that we're
gonna come up against in the long run
and this isn't quite ready for primetime
we also can take advantage of the
optical activity these qubits we use
that for readout and of course making
the gates but we can map the quantum
information itself on to single photons
either their polarization or their color
or their time delay many protocols for
that and you could imagine having a
bunch of registers of individual sets of
whatever 5 to 100 or even 1000 ion traps
that you've shuttled within one and then
you can map them on to others by by
mapping a given subset of these ions
onto single photons and the photons we
hear here we have a non-blocking cross
connects which fiber beam splitters and
a CCD array all this is classical it
exists and and you know the question of
integrating all this on the ion traps
the hardest part is right here just that
interface because we have an isolated
quantum system and now we want to
collect photons from it means that means
we need to get optics very close to
these atoms and that's why when we
started these experiments with only 2 to
separate the modules about a meter apart
we were connecting them at a
ridiculously slow rate of
about 2000 one Hertz every 10 minutes we
would get entanglement event now things
are a lot better we got foreigners of
magnitude simply by improving the optics
and because it's there are two photons
any little improvement we get to square
it so we're at about 10 per second now
we think we know how to push another few
orders of magnitude and when we do that
I put this up here when we do this it
becomes comparable to the speed of the
gates inside the module and that gives
you lots of opportunities for maybe
making it more optically intensive so we
need to get there to show that but as it
gets better and better it will implement
it will impact the high level
architecture of local versus remote
entanglement the big problem and you're
all I know you're thinking this if
you've seen an ammo lab the big problem
and all these experiments is that that
they look like this which is it
nightmare and in my I'm an ammo
physicist in my community people are
usually proud of experiments like this
like look look what I can do I can put
lots of cables together I think it's
ridiculous it's embarrassing and it's
pretty much the you know there's no
progress in a lab like that so
fortunately in the last few years we've
been afforded the opportunity to do a
system top-down version of this and
without much exaggeration at all
everything you see here except the grad
students can be compressed down to about
a meter cubed if you know what you want
to build you don't need the X Y Z knobs
on every optic so this is a very well
tightly integrated system it's funded
through our ARPA and it involved I
mentioned Harris on the modulators also
coherent makes our laser cold quanta
makes vacuum chambers AO sense makes the
CW lasers that we tuned for detection
and so forth and this system is still
under way but we have 32 beams
we don't worry about the ions that we
will we can probably trap 50 to 100 ions
in this in this trap made by Sandia but
it's more of the control from the
outside the laser beams that are the
tricky thing oh by the way a lot of this
this table here probably bout half of
this table has been compressed to a
single drawer made by AO sense again if
you know what you want to build it's
very easy to build it small and by the
way when things get small they also
perform better and if this looks like
something that is stretching what we can
do at a university it is and in fact we
can't hope to
and I can maintain this pace at the
University so there is a startup company
that's using this as the as this
hardware as the ground-floor of what
they want to do so I and Q is just off
University Maryland's campus we have
about 30 people now and only a third of
these people are quantum people most of
them are FPGA engineers RF microwave
engineers some silicon fab people a
little bit of that we fortunately have
we don't do our own fab and and of
course software API folks that will put
a system like this on the cloud
that's our goal at inq and this is
actually a picture from one of the inq
labs again this is all this can all be
condensed if we need to boo don't need
to there's no we're not going to deliver
this but there's the media cube version
inside the guts overtime queue so I'm
pretty bullish that we can certainly
push 232 at room temperature I have no
doubt about that I'm going to several
hundred by shuttling through through
more complex traps all the fundamentals
are there and I think you know you're
not gonna build 3200 unless you build 32
first and it's maybe stamp those out and
think about these modular approaches I
talked about before so my last slide I
like to quote my colleague Bill Phillips
in fact I noticed this and one of
Scott's the same this must be your
version of the quantum computer but he's
fond of Bill's fond of saying that yeah
literally yes it's a really big atom
there so bill bill was fond of saying
that a quantum computer this is no news
to the folks in this room but a quantum
computer is more different than a
classical computer than that classical
computer is to the abacus and what do
you mean here is theoretically these are
both Turing machines and they follow the
laws of classical physics even though
they look don't you know they don't look
like and you would you and you would
never factor a big number using an
abacus a really big number but on the
hardware side there's no reason to
expect that a quantum computer will look
anything like the classical computer
it's so different it's not just a more
powerful classical computer it's so
different that we need to look at
radical types of hardware because it's
very exotic to have such isolation of
any quantum system so I hope as time
goes on that we that other qubits come
to light in different forms and we're
able to engineer them so with that this
is a
a recent picture of the group and I will
acknowledge a couple of key
collaborators Jung si and Kim at Duke
who's an engineer he's been working on
ion traps for over 10 years really from
the system's level and also my colleague
Norbert linka who's now a faculty member
at the University of Maryland thanks for
attention
[Applause]
yeah we have on single qubit gates yeah
there's there's a pretty
well-established method for that and
actually Jung sang Kim has done more
than we have on that and I don't know
what the numbers I think it's five nines
or something ridiculous for a single C
go qubits
for two qubit gates we're starting to do
working with the group at Sandia this
this gates that tomography and I have to
say it doesn't seem to be a complete
you'll you'll laugh at me for my answer
but in that five cubic experiment our
AWG only has a depth of like a hundred
gates it's stupid so with our upcoming
system we're gonna have we'll have much
more to go so not a very satisfying
answer
oh yeah I skipped so many things um the
errors in our system are completely
dominated by induced errors from our
lasers the laser is either move around
in space or their their power changes in
time and you can't I mean you can't
always predict that and so that ends up
being an effective noise on the gates
it's not decoherence really but you can
think of it as decoherence if you want
it's a classical noise source on the
qubits the readout okay there are many
ways to answer this the readout I
mentioned is very clean but the one
thing I swept onto the rug is that we so
far and everything I've shown the
readout is global we read on all the
qubits at once I your question seems to
be leading toward error correction where
you might read out a fraction of them
and based on that do some kind of
correction operation we don't do that
yet with the 32 system we're going to be
able to do that by shuttling ions around
and we're gonna have multiple species
the vines in there where we can read out
one species keep it without touching the
other but so I'm not sure I'm not sure
I've exactly answer your question but
read out errors in general enough are
not what we worry about initialization
is even better than read out it's called
the optical pumping and it's very hard
to measure when you're better than six
nines of accuracy in your initial State
we're always limited by the readout in
accuracy which is more like three nines
or four nines
that's optical popping that's that's
super clean when you do them all at once
if you want to reset just one yeah
that's a little tricky is the limitation
basically the lasers that you have to
focus down and yeah it's it's it's
crosstalk now measuring is harder than
readout even though the sorry measuring
is harder than resetting I meant to say
resetting you don't need to get the
information and it only takes about ten
photons to get a very high probability
of resetting measurement you need to
scatter maybe a thousand photons and
there's if you're focusing on just one
qubit some of that light can spill out
and hit the others so Rhys
don't worry about so much which is good
if you wanna do error correction
actually you only need to reset as long
as you have gates it has an overhead of
gates but you're both thinking about air
correction I guess right my my feeling
about air correction and this will sound
this will sound like naive maybe is that
it won't play a role anytime soon in
anything we do that's probably for the
whole field yeah
it's playing with this exponent alpha
that describes the decay of the
interactions is like a little like going
from one dimension or to infinite
dimensional system alpha zero but still
what are the prospects of going to two
dimensional there's a different geometry
of iron trap called the penning try
didn't you mention this we are our trap
is called an RF trap or a pol trap and
it works best in 1d it only works in 1d
because it has RF fields it's a Quadra
pony you can only get a null of electric
field in 1d not enough dimensions around
to satisfy Gauss's law but a penning
trap uses not RF fields but a magnetic
field so the motion of a big string a
pancake of ions they undergo cyclotron
motion and you have to keep you know you
have to there's a lot of bookkeeping
there and they've done that in this and
they've done experiments with with
several hundred ions they don't have
individual addressing of those ions and
they also there are they're very soft
modes in that system because you have a
2d pancake there are rotational modes
shear modes there's super low frequency
they're hot they're noisy
and they're they have to by waller
factors which basically the crystal the
any coherent interaction is tempered by
it by those factors so the better way to
go to 2d is actually to have individual
atoms one at a time underneath some
arbitrary geometry of electrodes and the
hard part there is that you want these
ions to be close together a few microns
but that means that the they have to
also be a few microns away from a
surface if that surface is room
temperature even if it's cold you're in
trouble so the surfaces need to be in
our systems they're more like 80 microns
away and if you're 80 microns away your
eyes or 80 microns apart there's no
coupling so it's a little bit tricky to
work in multiple dimension
and so far it really hasn't gone
anywhere all right let's take a break
there and we'll continue at the
courteous